Oh
and those are the best video games that
came out on the vita this year there are
five nominees for best video game
against bots 2014 game of the year all
right let's start with the first one on
the list Olly Olly yeah the hardest
moving skateboards done twice why is
that on in this game of the month
January it was good boy from Byzantine
is so freaking hard but that's kind of
what makes it great like it's there's
this there are hurdles to get over but
they're not insurmountable right so you
struggle to pull off the moves with the
correct timing and keep a string of
moves going right and that's kind of the
basis of succeeding in this game but
once you begin to piece together these
these little skills like one after
another you really get into this flow
and it's just you know yeah it's a cute
little 2d game but but really it's a
really technical challenging experience
that just gets better as you learn and
become a better player and you can still
like and it's not just about achieving
sort of the bar that's set down for you
for a given level you you as you get
better and more fluid you try more and
you attempt more and you fight it harder
but then you like will and that super
awesome run that just like is everything
goes smoothly and it's all and your
heart's pumping at the end of it all
Rizzo getting that you can wipe down
your Vita they're sweaty oh that's the
best and like any handheld game it's
it's something that makes you once you
finish it you didn't make it quite as
far as you wanted like oh just one more
time like maybe I'll make it better next
time and then you do that again and then
again that's 3am you're deep in the
suburbs and how did you get there as
keeping with that sort of frantic
frenetic pace at velocity 2x a game that
was popular on PlayStation 4 as well and
of course on the PlayStation Vita yeah
this is a sequel to velocity really any
way more important this game mixes sort
of like it's some shmup elements and
then like some side-scrolling action
stuff but it's it's mostly about kind of
like you said about ollie ollie right
like doing the best you can as quickly
as you can I was playing this game on
the ps4 with my girlfriend the other day
she wasn't playing I but I was and she
and she was like I don't know if it's
just because I don't know what
doing or you're doing it really fast but
I cannot keep up with what's happening
at Green it's you know it's these
strings of simple maneuvers that you
learn and you sort of go through these
levels like teleporting shooting you
know defending and like when new burung
as quickly as you can and it's such an
invigorating little experience and these
moments go by so fast but they're
designed really well and you know you
might miss it but I think the fact that
it works so well is evidence of how good
or how well the game is designed it's
one of those games that seems so
completely ridiculously difficult when
you're looking when you first start
playing it like reminded me of like when
you play meat boy for the first time how
am I supposed to completely and then it
just becomes this weird sort of second
nature type thing changing pace quite
dramatically to a child of light a great
little game which I wanted to do this
entire section in Ryan and Sarah would
irritate you guys but would it yeah
that's probably the one criticism of
that game is that that that sort of
rhyming structure in the narrative a
little bit older that's what bothered me
I think maybe they thought they were
really clever when they decided to do
that and they spent a lot of time trying
to make it work yeah I bet it took a lot
of writing yeah but you know that aside
I think you know town of light works
really well on a few levels if one is
the combat system which is sort of
reminiscent of grandia where you sort of
you and you way that you know using
these moves right away to sort of like
have another move you know available to
you or whether you defend or counter and
that works really well and it's got a
really nice art style it's pretty
charming too and it's sort of unique in
the RPG world it's it's definitely a
European game but it has a lot of this
sort of touches that Japanese RPGs
really successful ones I've had in the
past and brought them to modern you I
love that story book artist out like
it's something that draws you in and
makes it feel like you're watching a
children's book I kind of living out in
front of you and that's our third
nominee our fourth freedom wars chris i
remember you hosted a live string for
this bad boy so when you're like going
into III like a lot of time you know the
big name games you know the games that
are coming across your plate but freedom
wars was one that was not on my radar
and all of a sudden I'm hosting this
demo and oh my god like this at this is
not only a game with like really
interesting combat mechanics but also a
sprawling like lengthy world like this
is not an 8-hour experience this is 40
hours this is more hours this is one of
those rich deep experiences that Keats
you you know keeps that Vita in your
pocket in your backpack for months and
months and months and you know we had
huge fans of this who would could speak
way more eloquently than I did and did
during our discussion to earn at the
nomination but it's one of these games
that like even you know even though we
all have you know you come in with your
experience of all the games you've
played all year and all the games you've
heard of you come out of that meeting
inevitably with the desire to play
something new yeah and this is one of
those games because the people who are
advocating for it we're just so
convincing and another game that I came
out of data meeting wanting to play and
it also wins the idania dwyer most
satisfying word to say 2014 is Duncan
rompa 22 I mean this is we got two of
these games in the same year the
danganronpa came out earlier in the year
danganronpa to for me it's hard to
decide which one is the one that should
be be nominated of course we were with
the second one because it's closer out
but there's just such a quirky mix of
visual novel it's kind of a continuation
in some ways if you played the 999 or
virtues last reward games this is the
kind of stuff that you're going to love
or if you love phoenix wright and that
kind of living out a story but going on
a much more crazy adult mixing some
minigames sort of way that's what Duncan
rough is excellence those are five
nominees for gang spots a game of the
year on PlayStation Vita 2014 and the
winners for that will be announced on
December 14 CUV defines make sure you
check back to gamespot com then